I know you you were advocating at the
Supreme Court I think it was last week
right because or maybe it was this week
that the Supreme Court is looking at
buying some giveaway to people who own
who giveaway is your term not my term
well we are they have college debt okay
and we're going to give the money we're
going to forgive that
well we're we're arguing about the same
thing but there was no argument we're
giving the money away okay so I just
want to read you this again this is
against why people sometimes I think
question some of what you're saying this
is a survey student loan forgiveness
recipient 73 of applicants say they are
likely to spend their extra money on
non-essential including vacations
smartphone drugs and alcohol they they
admitted that to the pollster who is
this postal I am
[Laughter]
NBC News
52 percent they are very likely or
likely to buy new clothing 46 they would
use the money for vacation and eat out
at restaurants this is why people have a
thing about I I would never call it free
money oh I guess I just did but
um well I mean let me respond to that in
two ways bill you talk about giveaways
under Trump the Congress voted for a
trillion dollars in tax breaks for the
richest people in this money in this
country and the largest corporations
that's a giveaway we just increased
military spending with very little
discussion I don't know if you know this
by 80 billion dollars military
industrial complex including the
Democrats the Democrats vote for it too
yes absolutely correct absolutely right
all right but that's socialism the
military that's crony socialism well
that's right crony capitalism but but
the military is in capitalism that's
that's the government no but it's who
owns the military industrial complexes
all right but anyway all right so when
you talk about giveaways you have major
corporations in this country that make
billions in profit don't pay a nickel in
taxes billionaires have an effective tax
rate lower than that of a truck driver
or a nurse you have a generation you
talk about this younger generation right
now I got around the country and I
talked to a lot of people you know I
don't know anything about that poll but
I can tell you I've talked to nurses who
are working their asses off doing the
right thing they leave school seventy
thousand dollars in that they can't
afford now to get married and have
children
they can't afford the housing that they
desperately need so the truth is you've
got a generation that everything being
equal the younger generation will have a
lowest standard of living than their
parents you and I and I'm a little older
than you can remember 50 years ago what
did it cost to go to the University of
California remember
50 bucks yeah 500 virtually free City
University New York right virtually free
and right now these young people are
leaving school deeply in debt they're
struggling economically they deserve a
break
yeah I couldn't agree more
um
and but in the in the book you say you
feel like the Democratic party uh and
you take your shots at them and you know
you're not you caucus with them and you
run as one but you're not completely
part of them uh you say they feel like
they're abandoned their cause to the
beautiful people who are The Beautiful
People
you're looking really beautiful today
here in L.A
me thank you Bernie
well here's the point the point that I
was making
is when FDR was president when Truman
was President even when JFK was
President you're out on the street and
you say to people which party represents
the working class of America most people
I think agree would have said the
Democratic correct all right today you
go out on the street and that is not the
sentiment in fact the Republican Party
probably has more adherence than the
Democrats how did that happen I'll tell
you how it happened it happened because
30 years ago the Democrats said hey
Republicans getting all this corporate
money we wanted to let's go out and get
it and let's forget about the people who
are working 50 or 60 hours a week so
you're sitting out there somewhere in
the Midwest
you can't afford health care
maybe your job went to China and you're
earning half of what you used to make
your kid can't afford to go to college
and you're looking at people on
television doing all of their stuff and
you are saying who the hell gives a damn
about me all right who cares what my
life is about who's addressing the
crises facing my life the pain that I'm
experiencing we have something I don't
know if you're familiar with the
Expressions called diseases of despair
of course all right and what the doctors
tell us we have a life expectancy above
and beyond covet which is in Decline
it's in decline because people feel
hopeless their jobs are taking them
nowhere worried about their kids and
they're turning to alcohol drugs and
even suicide all right we've got to
restore hope to the American people
working class on the majority of people
in this country they are hurting
after 50 years of exploding technology
they're earning less than they did than
they
did before all right they sound like
you're running again
now third time just talking about the
book time the charm you people usually
write a book when they're about to run
wow
no